les drogues que l'on retrouve en marché
libre dans les rues de montréal sont de
plus en plus dangereuse
la preuve en l'espace de deux semaines
il ya eu 14 intoxication sévère dont
neuf morts à montréal le coupable donc
ses drops de rue comme nous le dit anne
louise despatie c'est une véritable
épidémie de surdoses chez les
consommateurs de drogues de rue la
direction de santé publique de montréal
a documenté 14 cas depuis la mi mai dont
neuf morts c'est la moitié du nombre de
victimes qui meurent chaque année à la
suite d'injections de drogue
les 14 victimes avaient entre 20 et 64
ans parmi elles des gens qui ne se
piquer pas ou qui ne consommaient
qu'occasionnellement la drogue suspecte
est un médicament prescrit contre la
douleur
le fentanyl celle au pire et le plus
puissant qui qui existe au canada
actuellement qui se prescrit beaucoup
plus puissant que la morphine cléjà ne
savent pas ce qu'ils prennent ex un geiq
à leur quantité habituelle mais sont à
fort risque d'overdose
quand les gens peuvent ne pas penser que
ces drogues peuvent être coupés et puis
avoir des réactions qui sont très
importantes et ça c'est un phénomène qui
est plus nouveau
la dsp travaille avec la police et le
centre antipoison le phénomène est
alarmant les policiers détecte de plus
en plus la présence de produits ajoutés
aux drogues traditionnel la grc qui
dispose maintenant d'une application
mobile portant sur les risques et
tendances note que le fentanyl circulent
depuis 2011
le problème c'est qu'il ya une dérive de
ces médicaments prescrits sur le marché
noir
un timbre de fentanyl 2,5 microgrammes
par exemple le percevant 100 $ sur la
rue
le directeur de cet organisme dead dit
pierre lévesque qui a déjà consommé des
drogues dures constate de grands
changements dans les substances
aujourd'hui on retrouve toutes sortes de
produits qui sont ajoutés pour augmenter
la puissance des substances ou
d'accrocher les gens plus rapidement
plus que jamais les consommateurs ne
savent pas ce qu'ils prennent ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal